[موسيقى]
الخطه هو العمل التشريعي جاد في استعاده
الثقه عندما يلاحظ الشعب وان البرلمان
يعني يقوم بصلاحياته على احسن وجه وما
يتوافق مع الاراده الشعبيه عند ذلك سوف
نسترد ثقه الشعب في المؤسسه البرلمانيه
بالنسبه لعمل البرلماني
هو
الراي والراي المعارض
ومقارعه الحجه بالحجه
ويعني تقديم الراي ونقيض ثم استخلاص يعني
القرار الصحيح ولا يمكن ان يتحول البرلمان
الى حلبه صراع والى يعني
مسرح لتبادل
السب والشتم
والثلب لذلك
سوف تلاحظون بالنسبه لعمل البرلمان في
المستقبل والذي يبث في وسائل الاعلام يعني
مباشره في الجلسات وان العمل البرلماني
سيكون عمل صادق ونزيه وستكون
لنواب الحريه المطلقه في بدايه رايهم
وبطبيعه الحال هناك قناعات فكريه وهناك
قناعات سياسيه وكل سيدلو
يدلي بدلوه في الموضوع بكل حريه
[ضحك]
وبهاته الطريقه اعتقد اننا سنسترد ثقه
الشعب في العمل البرلماني
[موسيقى]
للمشاركه في الانتخابات في المواعيد
المستقبليه وعليه حال لا يوجد قانون في
تونس يمنع يعني نشات الاحزاب
[موسيقى]